hi and welcome to my video series of
small bio explained in three minutes
where I explain a concept of molecular
biology in less than three minutes it
might be short but it has all the
information to save your ass before the
day of exam so if you haven't yet
subscribed to my channel hit that
subscribe button what are you waiting
for
so in this installment we'll be talking
about the shuttle vectors so whenever
you hear the term shuttle what comes
into your mind so in my mind it reminds
me of a shuttle taxi or a shuttle cab
which take you from one place to another
place right so shuttle vector a simply
specially engineered plasmid which are
engineered in such a way that it can
propagate and it can segregate in two
different host species let's say a
bacteria and a eukaryotic species East
but you'd be surprised to hear that not
only in bacteria are East these show
infect the shuttle vectors can be used
to segregate plasmid from two different
strains of bacteria let's say one gram
positive and one gram negative bacteria
or even there are some adeno vector
adenovirus based shuttle vectors which
are used to propagate a plasmid between
equally and mammalian cells so shuttle
vectors are used to generally segregate
your plasmid in two different species so
now we'll look at some features of the
shuttle shuttle vectors and how they are
different from other vectors so first
feature is not unique which we talked
about first is the multiple cloning site
which would be a feature of every
cloning vector so where you clone your
gene of interest now since it would be
expressed in both species like both the
host species let's say for bacterial or
yeast so it should have host specific
promoters otherwise the transcription
and translation of from this vector is
not possible right so it should have
host specific promoter other than that
this plasmid should be replicated into
the both the hosts so it should have
let's say if it is between bacteria and
yeast it should have
origin of replication a selectable
marker in bacteria for example
antibiotic resistance gene similarly
let's see if it is a bacteria and yeast
shuttle vector it should have East areas
well it should have East selectable
markers let's sum you retrieve or
something like that it should have also
some sequences like a RS and centromeric
sequences which are essential for
propagating it inside the East right in
short these vectors has all the features
to clone it inside a bacteria or grow it
inside our East and that makes this
makes these vectors so useful so in
short we talked about that frontages so
the main advantages is like it can be
easily grown and manipulated inside a
bacteria so it's easy to grow plasmids
inside a bacteria right which is like
compatibly faster and easier to grow
them in eukaryotic species like East but
there are certain disadvantages of this
system that is it has low carrying
capacity and sometime it is not
compatible in the host and so on so
forth
so there are also some disadvantages
regarding these shuttle vectors but
however most of the expression vectors
these days which are used in mammalian
expression vector are shuttle vectors
which are pretty useful and they are
used to propagate it inside the e.coli
and then the manipulation is done in the
million cell I hope you enjoyed this
video if you like this video give it a
big thumbs up and don't forget to leave
your comments thank you